since its inception with 2013's Man of
Steel the DC extended universe
encountered obstacle after obstacle with
poor reviews mixed reaction from fans
and disappointing box office receipts
but there is one potential bright spot
on the horizon the upcoming flash solo
film which could act as a soft reboot of
the entire universe so cross your
fingers superhero fans because here's a
look at why the flash movie could fix
the DCE you flash to the rescue under
the guiding hand of director Zack Snyder
the DC EU was positioned as the dark and
gritty alternative to the bright and fun
Marvel movies but since being an
alternative to fun is a recipe for
failure
the folks at Warner Brothers have since
changed direction demoting Snyder in
promoting Walter Hamada to head of the
comic-book division in 2018 as an
attempt to lighten things up and with
the possible exception of Wonder Woman
no DC hero so far has been as bright and
upbeat as Ezra Miller's flash who added
some much-needed levity to 2017 s
Justice League if the DC EU is going to
write the ship the Flash's brand of
spunky fun may be exactly what Warner
Brothers and fans have been hoping for
flashpoint the Warner Brothers has
reportedly decided not to name the
upcoming flash film flashpoint as
originally planned it's still expected
that the movie will draw heavily from
the popular 2011 flashpoint comic book
storyline that's important because the
plot involves Barry Allen realizing he's
trapped in the wrong timeline and
teaming up with his fellow heroes to fix
time and restore reality to its true
form and that means that Warner Brothers
would have the perfect excuse to
jettison any details from their previous
DC EU films that fans and critics didn't
life things like potkins weird me first
lessons on selfishness and a morality
Superman killing Zod and the whole
Martha scene can be erased quicker and
more successfully than Henry cavils
mustache flashpoint gives Warner
Brothers a chance to totally rewrite the
history of the DC EU in order to create
a better future for its characters and
its fans the arrowverse if the plot of
flashpoint sounds familiar it might be
because the CW's flash TV series adapted
the comic for its third season storyline
and that suggests another opportunity
for the flash movie the multiverse in
the TV show of course flash and his pals
have discovered that there are lots of
alternate universes and timeline
comprising a multiverse which already
includes versions of Superman and
Supergirl among others it would be easy
and awesome for the film version of
Barry Allen to cross over and meet the
characters from the CW's arrow verse
considering flash has consistently been
one of the CW's most popular shows it's
the kind of fan service that could bring
a whole built-in audience to the
theaters and even give Warner Brothers a
rare leg up on Marvel which has
struggled to connect its TV shows to its
movies Elseworlds another benefit to
introducing the concept of the
multiverse to the DC EU is that it helps
explain not just all the previous
versions of DC super people that have
appeared on film but all the future out
of continuity movies Warner Brothers is
planning for instance it's been
announced that the upcoming Joker
standalone movie is already set to
appear in another timeline that could be
confusing for fans who just saw a new
version of Joker & Suicide Squad but if
flash introduces the DC eu2 Elseworlds
the name given to alternative universe
DC superhero stories everything will
still make sense and it would also allow
Warner Brothers to recast its big roles
with more ease with Ben Affleck
constantly rumored to be leaving as
Batman having some random new dude put
on the cowl could be jarring but if it
turns out Affleck is just a wrong
version of Batman from some Elseworlds
timeline accepting a new star in the
role could be a lot easier a tradition
of successful reboots fans who object to
the idea of rebooting the DC EU through
a flashpoint event this early on would
do well to remember that this wouldn't
be the first time a superhero franchise
has been rebooted and often with great
success the x-men series repeatedly
alters its continuity within the ongoing
story the Batman franchise was
revitalized by Christopher Nolan's
trilogy and even more recently Spiderman
was reinvigorated by Marvel's Tom
Holland LED take on the character and
just like how Holland's version of
spider-man found solo success after
breaking out of Captain America Civil
War Ezra Miller's flash could do the
same following his well received
appearance in Justice League
all while resetting the elements of the
DC menu that don't work in the process
sure it would be pretty fast for a
reboot but after all nobody is faster
than the flash Godspeed Barry Allen
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you left too
[Music]